talk about your YouTube special now
cracker okay well uh it's not the
easiest segue I'll be honest
put it out on black [__]
History Month it's called England oh
oh anything wrong to black people
historically speaking they have
apologized privately many times for what
they did it's called England weed and
the rest and uh you can go to
garethrenolds.com you're really gonna
change the title I think yeah I don't
know if I'm beyond being able to do that
but I definitely think you should change
it what should you change it to the
death of the comedian
now we onto something yeah I like that a
lot better but you guys can pick I'll
call it that oh
[Music]
yeah
I think you should vote about it close